the southeastern city of joshua of
poland is as close as the u.s president
joe biden has come so far to russia's
war on ukraine
into russia it's his first chance to
speak with u.s troops now stationed
there
ukrainian people have a lot of backbone
they have a lot of guts
and i'm sure you're observing
what's your name
the city is less than 100 kilometers
from ukraine's border and it's where
roughly 10 thousand u.s troops are
positioned ready to take on russia
should it expand its invasion into the
nato country
it's a conflict biden told soldiers he
believes could have long-term
ramifications
our democracy is going to prevail on the
and the values we share
or autocracy is going to prevail
that's really what's at stake
more than 3 million people have been
displaced from ukraine since russia's
invasion
because of ukraine's more than 500
kilometers shared land border with
poland more than two million people have
fled to the neighboring country
we'd like to ask america and their
leaders to please support ukraine so
ukraine is not attacked by the russians
americans should stop rockets flying in
our airspace this is the most important
thing because all of those rockets are
terrible like a nightmare
biden has vowed to help manage the
migrant crisis emerging along poland's
border with ukraine but he won't commit
to implementing a no-fly zone on friday
as biden met with poland's president he
once again accused russian president
vladimir putin of war crimes for
targeting civilians in ukraine
i quite frankly think as a war criminal
but biden isn't just promising
humanitarian assistance before departing
brussels on friday the united states and
european union announced a new agreement
to provide the eu with extra gas
equivalent to about 10 percent of what
it currently gets from russia by the end
of the year
biden hopes to choke out russia's energy
revenue and in turn military funding
but on saturday president biden sits
down with president duda in the royal
castle behind me for a more lengthy
discussion on the conflict
it's biden's final opportunity to
reassure a nervous ally in person of the
u.s and nato commitment to defend poland
should russia make poland its next
target
kimberly hellcat al jazeera warsaw